we had a magnitude 7.8 earthquake
hitting one day when we are 50 meters
away from the summit so you can't
obviously plan for that no you can't and
that's the acts of God you know uh
working with NASA uh although I am the
director of the city Institute I uh my
grants are coming from NASA so I'm a
NASA contractor and every time we go to
those environments we have to go through
the rigorous process of training with
NASA and checking all the boxes for
safety so they are training and training
and training us and I have to thank them
because a lot of those trainings are the
things that are in your brain when these
kind of things happen you know how to
react and you are not freaking out but
in all of the things they are training
us for you have the green risk the
yellow risk and the red risk so the
green risks are basically the don't be
stupid they don't do the kind of thing
you wouldn't be doing at home like it's
jumping you know on rocks that are not
stable you can tweak your ankle you know
and then you have other risks like high
altitude sickness how you prepare for
that how you recognize that these are
the yellow risks and then the red risk
the red bricks are what they call the
acts of gods the kind of thing that they
can happen you know there is nothing you
can do about it and then you accept that
when you do that so those are
volcanic eruptions when you're in this
kind of environment earthquakes
and everything that an Avalanches for
instance so you're in this Giant
mountain and it's shaking no it's not
shaking that's the interest think part
of it there was a whole background of
things that happened that day when we we
started off but we got to 50 meters from
the summit and I have part of my
Logistics team that is at the foot of
the mountain and being so close to the
summit we have to go under other hand of
lava so it's just like we are just under
this big Vault of lava and it's actually
beautiful if you want something
beautiful is the ultiplano scene from 20
000 feet it's just absolutely stunning
The Colors the colors are that of early
Earth which means primordial Earth it
occurs yellows oranges browns
with a dark blue sky and so you're just
you know it's a time machine you're just
out there and you're climbing 42 degree
slopes so all of a sudden I'm right next
behind the guide and the guy that's been
with us it's family you know we've been
together for 10 years and he's starting
to do that
I don't discuss when Macario do that you
know I I listen and I ask the team to do
the same thing where maybe half a dozen
and then I want to talk to him and say
what's going on is on the radio and then
he gives me the radio I'm talking to my
logistic chief officer who was at the
bottom and he said we're having a
tremendous earthquake
uh it was saying that the uh actually
the ground was waiting it was so bad
and it was freaking out because he said
everything is avalanching and I'm very
puzzled because we are in a very
dangerous part of the volcano nothing's
happening I turn around and then this is
when I realized there is just absolutely
everywhere
everything that I saw two minutes before
it's gone just disappeared into a wall
of dust but nothing's happening where we
are and uh our our friends down uh they
were freaking out because they were
seeing everything avalanching and
especially the other side of the
mountain we were on was a Vanishing so
they have no visuals they have no visual
they thought that we are caught in the
Avalanche so I said no but some uh so at
that point they thought you were screwed
yeah and I said okay so if this is
what's happening then I'm taking
everybody
to the summit because we have a very
large crater that will take care of
avalanching will be safe and I'm waiting
for the Aftershock because this is what
you do uh you know when you have
earthquakes so here we go taking
everybody in the crater and now you have
half a dozen scientists in the crater
with the Cradle Lake and this is why we
came for so we just had a 7.8 earthquake
and what do you think they do well of
course they do the signs they came to to
do so the only thing is that I couldn't
because my radio was only working when I
was on the rim of the Creator but I had
a little assistant with me a a young
Bolivian teenager had been shadowing me
for three weeks so I knew exactly what
to do and he said no you don't no
problem give me your back I'll do the
sampling for you so I was monitoring uh
the situation and I'm scared
I wasn't at that point
and
there was another moment my friend
downstairs I could you know at the foot
yeah we've known each other as I said
we're family this team is family we've
known each other I am the gunmather as
kids so we we are close
and I could feel for the first time in
in my life that he actually was scared
and he was calling me every 30 seconds
telling me stuff I said you have to stop
this now
just call me to give me information that
is useful for me to make decisions
and so
um I say okay what's going on all right
it tells me you know there is still
avalanching Etc and then a few minutes
later he calls me to say I think that
last car is erupting so now I have to
tell you we are on a volcano the next
volcano we share a slope with it is a
low a little lower but that's the most
temperamental volcano of the entire
chain and this one as an history of
eruption and then my friend is telling
me that the volcano seems to be starting
to erupt if that volcano goes up we have
nowhere to go
that got my attention
so if you say scared I would say that I
got the realization that what that meant
I went called for like a fraction of a
second but that meant that just my
adrenaline started to kick in and it was
a very very strange experience because
now you have tunnel vision it's about
survival and I say okay now you are
going to tell me what I need to know you
know tell me what do you see say I see
smoke say what kind of smoke you say
it's white I say no big deal that's
water vapor okay where it's going it's
going to Argentina that was the opposite
direction where we are I said okay I'm
staying where I am because right now
there is no you know no danger
and there are still the issue of the
Aftershock
I didn't want to have the team caught in
the Gully in the central Gully of the
volcano with an avalanche coming at us
so sit there
and he called me after that and say well
you know it's still going to Argentina
fine okay
um and then a little later he calls me
and say Natalie
um things are changing here say okay
what's going on I say well the clad is a
little yellow
and I was thinking myself
what does it mean when it's yellow
sulfur and then when you have sulfur
mixed with the water vapor or the water
in your lungs this turns into sulfuric
acid
then you're really screwed
and I say okay
um where thank you for the information
where where is the club going is it the
wing is Shifting it's coming your
direction
so yeah that was a day like that you
know and I am talking to him on the
radio and I'm turning around and as I
turn around I see the clouds starting to
pop on the opposite side of the rim you
know
so at that time we had no choice anymore
because now you have to figure out
what's going to kill you first and so
there was the risk or the potential of
an avalanche
but at least you can see the rocks
the guest is going to kill you before
you can see it yeah so I called
everybody back we got our stuff
um I didn't give too much detail but I
say it's time to go
downhill and fast
so which we did we stopped only when we
were at Mid camp and then at that point
we saw the cloud just completely
covering the summit where we were so we
did well to bail out
but that was 500 meter
500 meter high oven and we were so we
are safe I was just making sure that it
would not go down the slope where we
were we were safe so we stayed and you
know just rested for a little while and
after that we descended and it was all
on adrenaline I can tell you what I had
two on my crew with headaches as part of
one of them was because of the altitude
we climbed very fast the other one was
because of the cloud she was the closest
to the cloud when uh it happened so we
didn't send it fast wow that was close
that was close and it's interesting how
the human body and mind works because I
know that from the moment my friend told
me that the volcano seemed to be
erupting I was going on adrenaline
but when we got close to them and I saw
him we are getting close to the cars I
saw him come in towards me and the slope
all of a sudden all the adrenaline went
away
I was a mess I had to find the first
rock and sit down yeah it was gone I
mean fascinating so you just basically
physically and mentally collapsed once
you saw so there was nothing left of me
I got in the car and I felt in the cars
we were heading back towards a camp I
could have passed out I really fought
back and I'm not the kind of passing out
really you know easy but there was
nothing left I had no energy no nothing
it's fabulous how you react and how this
is embedded in your brain from
and of evolution of reaction to a
dangerous situation basically
the drive to survive yeah something like
that